salut comme dirait orelsan aujourd'hui
on revient aux basiques c'est à dire
qu'on va faire un master class pour
apprendre à multiplier ensemble de tête
est hyper rapidement des chiffres
jusqu'à 20 x 20 genre 17 x 19 par
exemple et on va pas s'arrêter là
pourquoi je vais vous le dire pourquoi
puisque déjà moi ça faisait longtemps
que j'étais pas dans les vidéos parce
qu'il ya une méthode qui existent pour
faire ça avec des chiffres quand jusqu'à
160 genre 67 x 97 comme salle de tête
ces astuces là c'est technique là je les
connaissais pas mais comme vous savez je
me forme en permanence et je les ai
découvertes ya quelques mois par un
pacte qui s'appelle david tient à peu
près les mêmes passions chelou que moi
et qui a ouvert une chaîne l'année
dernière qui s'appelle nemo note donc
c'est parti et juste avant de commencer
j'en profite aussi pour vous remercier
vous êtes déjà 200 à avoir réservé pour
le spectacle à l'olympia de l'année
prochaine soit déjà 10% de la salle
c'est très très gros 10% de la salle
c'est cool donc les meilleurs sièges
commence à partir je vous invite à
réserver dès que vous pouvez si vous
savez que vous voulez venir
déjà parce que vous aurez les places les
moins chères et vous pourrez choisir le
placement vous allez ça en descriptions
alors la première question que vous
posez à la normale c est ce que c'est
vraiment aussi simple que ça de pouvoir
calculer jusqu'à 160 comme ça de tête je
pose la question à david est-ce que
c'est aussi simple que ça bonjour fabien
et merci et oui les tables de
multiplication c'est en a vraiment
impressionné plus d'un je dirais même
presque dégoûté des mathématiques c'est
le début du moment où on s'est dit je
vais être nul en maths et en vrai c'est
pas si compliqué et il ya des vrais
astuces pour rendre ça hyper simple bon
c'est vrai je vous rassure quand il m'a
expliqué cette méthode la gelée comprise
instantanément et j'ai pu le reproduire
tout de suite donc je vais je vais te
laisser david nous expliquer comment on
fait de manière basique et après moi je
vous réexpliquer manière un peu plus
imagé donc l'astuce qu'on va voir
aujourd'hui c'est par exemple des
multiplications pour les longues entre
10 et 20 parce que les tables jusqu'à 9
jusqu'à 10 comme ça les faire si facile
mais un 17 x 15 tu fais comment alors le
17 x 15 il faut le rendre assez visuel
et on verra que c'est pas si
impressionnant on croit et moi je les
pose comme ça en général je mets le plus
grand héros est le plus petit en bâton
le 17 x 15 et je vais rendre les choses
très simples la multiplication par dix
on le sait elle est facile en 15 et
j'enlève tout ce qu'il faut pour arriver
à 10 dont classés 5es jeux le montant au
donc 17 + 5 22 ok on est d'accord c'est
interdit dans les multiplications
normalement faire des additions
soustractions entre les produits tu vas
voir où je vends donc j'ai 1 22 euro et
j'ai un 10 ans bah 22 x 10 220 ça
c'était pas très compliqué et il nous
reste les deux unités nos deux produits
le 7 et le 5
on va multiplier entre et ça nous donne
un cette fois 5,35 et là je prends mon
je prends mon 220 255 17 fois qu'un ça
fait 2 155 et vous verrez que vous
saurez faire des calculs assez fou en un
rien de temps alors comme ça peut-être
ça vous paraît floue pour la première
fois mais je fais là capituler les
étapes sont très simple vous allez les
deux chiffres entre 10 et 20 que vous
les multipliez ensemble vous mettez dans
votre tête ou sur le papier peut-être
pour vous entraîner une fois le plus
haut au dessus on fait ça par exemple
pour 16 x 18
eh ben on va mettre le 18e dessus le
saison de soude dans notre tête deuxième
étape on va transférer les unités du
plus faible au nombre le plus fort donc
le 6 de 16 on va l'envoyer sur le 18 ce
qui va nous donner 24 x 10 deuxième
étape bis parce que franchement entre
vous et moi on va pas dire que c'est une
troisième étape
on va finir cette multiplication du 24 x
10 a fait 240 ça ça va c'est un truc
vous maîtrisez je le sais donc la
troisième étape ça va être de multiplier
ensemble les deux unités de départ donc
le 8l 6,6 fois huit ça fait 48 ça c'est
sûr que dès qu'on veut faire du calcul
de tête faut connaître notable de base
bien dans notre cerveau on a donc le 48
qui traîna c'est le 240 est bon on va
additionner les 2 48 et 240 ça fait 288
essais soit 18,6 vous verrez clé ça fait
bien de 188 si on compte les petites
étapes seulement 4 5 étapes mais
réellement dans votre cerveau ça se fait
en trois phases
le transfert des unités pour faire une
multiplication par dix la multiplication
des unités ensemble et l'addition des
deux c'est tout c'est aussi simple que
ça est-ce que franchement c'est pas
brillant
moi je trouve que c'est brillant j'ai vu
un kiff quand j'ai découvert ça ben
alors une fois que je suis faire ça et
je vous assure que si vous le faites
deux trois quatre cinq fois vous êtes
capable de le faire pour toute votre vie
instantanément ça le fait j'ai demandé à
david s'il n'y avait pas une méthode
pour aller jusqu'à 100 fois sans
apparemment je n'étais pas le premier à
lui demande
et donc il a aussi une méthode pour ça
évidemment tu le sais j'ai des les
internautes d essuie des followers sur
youtube qui me pousse toujours à aller
plus loin c'est bien le 10 soit 20 mai
va plus loin à ce que tu peux nous
emmener au 160 façon facile alors oui
c'est possible je me muni d'un outil et
si tu prends un 64 x 85 tu vas voir que
juste le fait de l'avoir comme ça de
visu si x 8 48 5 points 4 20 ensuite
j'ai 6 x 5 et 4 x 8 32 et 30 62 48 20 ça
doit être un 5440 on pourra vérifier
mais ça va assez vite est la méthode je
ne sais pas si tu la connais c'est alors
là je pense que vous êtes comme moi la
première fois qu'il m'a fait ça j'ai
compris ce qu'il faisait au fur à mesure
qu'il faisait mais j'ai pas compris
comment il a assemblé tout ça pour en
faire un résultat final là en plus il
est sympa il vous l'a fait sur le papier
je voulais explique rapidement cherchait
pas à retenir mais je vous explique
juste le concept rapidement imaginons
qu'on va multiplier ensemble par exemple
53 x 80 dans un premier temps on va
multiplier ensemble les dizaines donc 5
x 8 cm 40 et les unités 3 x 1 ça fait 3
on va sur écrire ça ou mieux l'imaginer
dans notre tête qui a 40 d'un côté et
trois de l'autre ensuite en parallèle de
ça on va faire un truc alors vraiment ne
cherchez pas le retenir c'est juste pour
vous expliquer mais la phrase en
elle-même va être très compliqué on va
faire l'addition du produit de la
première dizaine
avec la deuxième unité plus la 2e la
première unité avec la deuxième dizaines
ok donc en clair on va faire cinq fois
un + 3 x 8
ce qui nous donne 29 et ce 29 là on va
l'insérer dans le trou qu'on avait
laissé entre le 40 et le 3 sachant qu'il
y a que l'unité qu'on met dans le trou
parce que la dizaine on va l'associer
aux héros du 40 soit 4293 alors là oui
je vous entends dire et vous avez raison
oui c'est trop compliqué que votre
expliqué on a rien compris c'est normal
on a rien compris parce que david sur sa
chaîne il l'a vraiment expliqué détaillé
je vais pas lui prendre son travail
si vous voulez vraiment connaître toutes
les étapes pour ça vous allez sur la
chaîne de la vie
nemo note et vous avez toute
l'explication avec tous les cas de
figure d'ailleurs petite question en
passant à david moi je fais des
recherches en permanence je m'intéresse
à tout ce qui existe comme technique et
comme nouvelle technique également
j'essaie également de trouver les
miennes mais j'aimerais bien savoir
quels sont tes sources en fait pour
trouver ce genre de choses alors les
astuces je les ai pas inventés en tout
cas pas tout et j'ai des vraies sources
alors les sources bas je dirais c'est
des gens comme toi parce que toi aussi
tu en donnes dans tes vidéos dans son
livre mon cerveau est extraordinaire et
puis une vraie source pour moi ça a été
arthur benjamin il a fait une série de
dvd et vidéos sur le net qui sont en
anglais et qui donne des super astuce
est ce qui est intéressant c'est que la
soir ça peut être vous si vous aussi
vous avez des petites astuces comme ça
en mal des petits trucs qui permettent
de faire des déçus des skill en plus à
des petits ac rapide de calcul mental
vous pouvez nous les met dans le dans
les commentaires
je lirai ça avec intérêt même si ça vous
paraît juste une toute petite astuce
toute bête
l'idée c'est de les compiler je pense
que j'en ferai une vidéo avec tout vos
astuces à vous en prenant des scripts de
votre commentaire et en les commentant
ou en les améliorant peut-être si
parfois je connais des trucs qui
permettent d'aller encore plus loin
et tant que vous y êtes n'oubliez pas de
mettre un pouce bleu à cette vidéo parce
qu'un pouce plus simples aux plus
s'impose plus un pouce a fait plein de
pousser et ça c'est plutôt cool
david de la chaîne nemo noté moi ça fait
plus 3 4 ans je crois qu'on se connaît
six ans et plus et dans ces cas là il va
râler comme je le disais il a ouvert sa
chaîne et un petit peu plus d'un an
si vous aimez tout mais master class mes
astuces il ya de grandes chances que
vous appréciez le travail de david je
t'aime est présente et achêne en
quelques secondes d'ailleurs donc fabien
j'anime une chaîne sur youtube qui
s'appelle mené mono qui en vrai
s'adresse à tous ceux qui se sont dit un
jour dans leur vie alors moi je suis nul
en multiplication en maths en anglais je
sais pas retenir les prénoms les numéros
de téléphone mon numéro de carte bleue
j'oublie la géographie c'est pas mon
fort et bien c'est un petit peu ça que
j'apporte à mener nos notes c'est toutes
ses clés parce que si j'avais eu en
étant en collège ou au lycée
toutes les méthodes que je connais
aujourd'hui ma scolarité elle aurait
rien eu à voir avec ça voilà peu plus d
internet vous savez tous merci beaucoup
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo prenait
quelques secondes pour souffler pour
vous entraîner
ça vaut le coup parce que au-delà de
faire poser la calculatrice ce genre de
méthode ça permet d'améliorer
visualisation et de reformer son cerveau
aux traitements multiples et rapides et
ce bénéfice là il est bien au delà
ensuite du calcul mental
n'oubliez pas de soutenir la chaîne et
de vous abonner à très bientôt ciao
alors ce premier rond sur ma droite si
tu fais un clic de suisse à ta bonne âme
à chaîne et ya une personne sur deux qui
regardent les vidéos qui pas abonnés
alors c'est l'occasion de le faire on
n'hésite pas et l'autre auront qu'il
faut c'est à côté
c'est la fameuse chaîne de mémos note de
david qui a fait cette vidéo avec moi
merci beaucoup à lui et puis on va pas
se mentir
un grand merci à vous